okay i guess we should get started
um welcome back from the break
and now for something completely
different
uh satan is going to talk about learning
deep rally networks
so go ahead
we can't see your slides though
take your time
yep we can see them now but you're muted
can you hear me now there we go it's all
yours
all right excellent
um great so um i'm having to talk about
joint work today um
with uh adam clivens and raghumeka on
the question of learning uh deep
rayleigh networks
okay so at a high level uh the
motivation for this
talk is the age-old question of pac
learning so given labeled examples from
some distribution
you would like to output some predictor
f hat that achieves low test error on
the original distribution
okay so the practitioner's tool of
choice for this particular question
would be simply to run sgd to train a
large deep neural network on these
examples
and use that as the predictor okay so
it's no secret that this works great on
real world data
an essential mystery in the theory of
deep learning that's been the focus of a
ton of talk
a ton of work over the last few years is
why this seems to work so well in
practice
not only from an optimization
perspective but from the generalization
perspective that we focus on
okay um right so the first question can
ask is why does sgd seem to work so well
in practice
but apart from asking what's so great
about this particular algorithm or
family of algorithms
you can also just ask the broader
question of why
real-world data seems to allow us to
evade well-known worst-case hardness
results for learning neural networks and
so in that spirit you could ask a second
question which is for which
distributions d is this particular task
tractable for any polynomial time
algorithm not just sgd
okay so these two questions are clearly
related on a
spiritual level and on a technical level
and i would argue that they at their
core get at a much more ambitious agenda
which is to design more principled
ideally provable algorithms
for this particular problem that out the
outperform existing techniques on any
number of axes
like speed sample efficiency robustness
uh what have you
okay so in this talk um i'm going to
focus on question two
and specifically i'm going to focus on
an instantiation of question 2 that's
been well studied
in recent years and that's the question
of learning a teacher network
okay so we're going to assume that the
labels y
i actually come from some unknown neural
network f okay
so just gonna focus on the realizable
case in this talk
great okay so uh what is a neural
network so we'll focus on
this particular concept class
of feed forward networks so specifically
we have
some collection of weight matrices w1
through wl
and more succinctly you could write this
resulting function
as follows okay and
right so how this function computes an
output a scalar output y
is that you take your d dimensional
vector x
um and you uh left multiply it by some
weight matrix
pass it through an entrywise rayleigh
function left multiplied by a weight
matrix et cetera okay and at the output
layer
we have just a single vector which
computes an inner product between
that vector and the vector of
activations up to that point
okay and the output is some scalar value
y
okay so some parameters of interest for
this question are the ambient dimension
d
which we should think of as extremely
large
we should also let's also define l to be
the
depth of the network which i've defined
here to be the number of weight matrices
let's let the size
denote the total number of columns
across all of these weight matrices
okay so it's the sum of the case of i's
from 1 to l minus 1.
okay so an important
parameter in in this entire setup is a
notion of effective dimension
so let me motivate that a bit so a feed
forward network you can think of as
not just a function from d dimensions to
one dimension
but really a function that maps uh
points inside
the span of the columns of w1 transpose
to points in r okay so in particular
this function only really depends on
the projection of x to the column span
of w1 transpose
and all components orthogonal to it
don't affect
you know the activations of the first
layer and for that reason because i'm
interested in the column span of w1
transpose
i'm going to define the so-called
effective dimension k to be the rank
okay and uh in this talk we're going to
think of k
as being much smaller than the ambient
dimension and in fact
we're going to think of the overall size
of the network as being much smaller as
well
okay so any questions about this up
all right great okay so this is the
concept class we'll be working with
um and we're interested in just the
following basic pac learning question
given labeled examples where the xis are
drawn from some possibly known
distribution d sub x
and the labels are simply the output of
this neural network
when evaluated on a particular x
our goal is to output a network g which
is close to f
in l2 okay
all right so that's the goal and uh in
this in this work we're going to focus
on the standard setting
where the distribution over covariates
is fairly benign
namely we'll assume that d sub x is uh
standard gaussian d dimensions
oh satan um ilious wants to know already
why
you're not solving an even harder
problem oh
sorry where is the uh there's noise
added to that let me look at the chat
ah good good yeah yeah so um uh yeah
it'll become evident when i talk about
the techniques that
uh we can handle sort of benign noise um
but for simplicity i'm gonna focus on
the realizable case yeah
and that's how the you know that's how
the paper is structured but uh
we believe that uh the scout intuition
uh
shouldn't be too much of a problem
that's a good question um so yeah just
for this talk let's focus on just
the noiseless case great
um okay all right so
good so now let me give a brief overview
of some of the prior approaches
um and i want to give a bit of a flavor
of what kinds of techniques go into
showing these results
okay so um so the question of learning
rayleigh networks uh has
uh had an extensive line of work in past
few years
um and at least in the gaussian case all
works
focus on the depth of most two case all
right so this is
the picture i showed in previous slides
specialized to l equals two
and you can think of f as uh being
written this more compact form where you
have
a linear combination of rayleighs of
inner products of the input
with various vectors okay
and so this might be a bit of an
oversimplification um so i apologize if
i
omitted some works but at a very high
level
i think of these existing results on
learning
depth two networks as sort of falling
into three categories
the first are results that essentially
use some form of spectral or tensor
method
stemming from what amounts basically to
science lemon
the second category are techniques based
on kernel methods and the third category
are algorithms that
analyze the dynamics of gradient descent
either from a local convergence
perspective or a global one okay so the
second category
is somewhat orthogonal to the thrust of
this work
in that they make the assumption that
the inputs are bounded in norm
but as a result they're able to handle
much more general distribution
assumptions as long as the inputs are
supported
in the unit sphere or unit ball okay so
we'll primarily focus on one and three
which apply to the gaussian case and
it's safe to say that all of these
results essentially need to assume some
combination of the following two
assumptions um the first being that the
lambda i's these coefficients which
you should think of as the entries of
the final vector w
two um so the assumption is these are
positive
and other works make the assumption that
the wis
which are the column vectors of w1
transpose
are essentially nearly orthogonal so you
can think of it as just that the
condition number of w1 is good
okay so now let's uh so i'm going to
focus on uh
you know the stein's lemma and gradient
method based uh
results but before i get into the
details of that let me just
mention briefly that one reason why
existing results have
focused on this particular set of
assumptions or any set of assumptions
at all is that the goal has been a bit
different
than the goal of pac learning in this
talk namely most of the existing works
have focused on parameter learning
okay so why do you need to make extra
assumptions
in the setting of parameter learning
well you know it's it's not hard to see
that you can cook up
uh sets of uh neural networks that have
different architectures and weight
matrices
but which all give rise to the same
function okay so here's a very silly
example
right so if i take a neuron i subtract
it from itself it's going to compute the
zero function
and you can cook up slightly more
sophisticated examples
okay so if your goal is parameter
learning namely to actually
given samples output a network whose
parameters are close to the true ones
you had better make some assumptions in
order to guarantee
that the parameters of the true network
are
uniquely identifiable from samples okay
and a very common assumption in this
vein would then be to assume something
like a condition number bound for the
weight matrices
okay the the point i want to make is
that
such assumptions are not operary
necessary
for pac learning rayleigh networks okay
okay so now let's let's give a sense for
how these existing results leverage
this kind of condition number bound
assumption or the positivity assumption
and i'll start with techniques based on
spectral tensor methods
okay so uh at a high level these these
results
use just the following fact the
following property for gaussian
distributions
which is that uh if i take the
expectation
of y times x and x is gaussian and y is
computed by f
then this is equal to the expected
gradient of f evaluate over the gaussian
okay and for one hidden layer i can
evaluate this explicitly this is going
to be some linear combination
of the weight vectors wi
okay and this sometimes goes by the name
of you know degree one shot parameters
okay and you can take this one step
further you could look at degree two
child parameters
and you could form the matrix
expectation of y times x x transpose
minus identity
and this gives you back the expected
hessian
and this is then going to be some linear
combination of
rank 1 matrices projectors to the
spans of wis
and you can take this to its logical
conclusion and at degree m
um there is some tensor valued function
called the emit score function
so that if you form this statistic it
gives you back the m
derivative tensor of f and then you can
compute this and this is going to be
some linear combination
of tensor powers of wi okay
and this is the specific form for the
score function
okay so the details of this aren't super
important but what i want to emphasize
is that all of these statistics
involve computing some expectation
of a product of y with a function of x
okay so that's the main takeaway now how
do these
these results leverage this kind of
these objects okay
so if you assume that the weight matrix
in the first layer is well conditioned
then morally the wi's are nearly
orthogonal
and then you can just run your favorite
tensor decomposition algorithm on the m
equals three tensor
and recover the parameters uniquely
okay on the other hand if i don't assume
that
my weight vectors are well conditioned
and i'm happy to do just pack learning
um then a recent work of diaconicallus
uh
kane kotonis and zarifis showed that
you can you can do something using the n
equals two object okay
so why are lambda i's being positive
helpful
um you can show that the resulting b sub
i coefficients here
are positive and so intuitively
you know you're not getting any kinds of
cancellations in particular
the resulting matrix y times x x
transpose minus identity
is going to be a sum of rank 1 matrices
right and the point is that in this case
because it's a sum of rank 1 matrices
the span of the weight vectors wi
you can recover from the top k singular
subspace of m
okay so you've already recovered sort of
the the hidden subspace on which your
function depends
uh by looking at the svd of this matrix
m
and once you have this you know
relatively small dimensional subspace
you can hope to exhaustively enumerate
over it
okay so this will incur some exponential
in k
and recently um another work of dia
colony colos and kane
used a much more sophisticated variant
of this technique involving sort of the
tensor generalization of
this m equals two matrix um and they
manage to
drive the dependence on k down to quasi
polynomial
okay um but anyways the main takeaway
from the slide should be that all of
these sort of interact with the
distribution
via expectation of y times some function
of x
okay now let's move on to the next
technique um
so i'm not going to describe in detail
how the analysis
works in these results but let me just
say something very simple which is that
if you
want to do green descent with respect to
the square loss this is what your
gradient update will look like for one
hidden layer
and the point is that i can write this
in such a way
that i have two terms one term which is
again some kind of expectation
over y times a function of x
and then some expectation over a
function which is purely depending on x
okay so this thing i know the underlying
distribution of x's so i can in
principle evaluate this explicitly
and all the action is really going on in
this statistic
okay and let me mention you know this is
for square loss
but and there are some really nice works
that look at modifying the loss function
to make the
optimization landscape more benign but
suffice to say that all of the existing
works that use gradient methods for this
problem
still need to use updates of this
general form
and only apply in the case where the
lambda i's are positive and the wi's are
well conditioned
and the reason is that really the
analysis goes into showing
convergence in parameter distance
okay so this brings up the the natural
question
can we pack learn without assuming
either of these assumptions
okay and so very recently
two groups of researchers showed that
there's actually a fundamental barrier
to answering this particular question
and the key insight that they made was
this point that i've been
sort of hammering repeatedly which is
that
all the approaches i've described so far
could have been implemented not with
samples but just with an oracle
that can answer queries of the following
form
i give the oracle some function from d
dimensions
to one dimension and the oracle spits
out
a noisy estimate of expectation of y
times g of x
okay um and so
it was shown recently by goylet all and
dioconeticals at all
that any algorithm that only interacts
with your
underlying distribution in this fashion
uh can't hope to learn
general two-layer rayleigh networks even
to constant error
without making roughly d to the size
number of queries okay
so this is a pretty strong no-go result
that you know rules out the kinds of
approaches i've described in the
previous slides
and so the the focus of this work is
really of this current talk is going to
be
can you produce any polynomial time
algorithm that can learn
general two-layer rayleigh networks in
time uh
less than this lower bound okay
and the other question we're gonna we're
gonna tackle is uh can we finally
hope to go beyond depth too
okay so these are the main questions um
are there any
questions from the audience before i
continue
okay great um right so now let me tell
you about uh the results
um before going into the techniques
okay so uh before i describe our results
here's just a
picture of the concept class we're
interested in it again um and i'll keep
this box of
relevant parameters up on the top right
okay so our main result uh or at least a
baby version of it
is that for any depth l regular network
for which the weight matrices are bound
in an operator norm
or specifically that the product of the
operator norms is bounded by some
parameter b
then we can properly pack learn capital
f to error epsilon
with the following sample complexity and
runtime guarantees
so the sample complexity is going to
scale just linearly
in the ambient dimension and it has some
extra
exponentially large term that depends on
the error
and these various parameters okay
on the other hand the runtime uh so so
let me just to remind you
uh k here is the effective dimension so
usually it was the the rank of the first
weight matrix
b is this uh operator norm bound which
uh
you know uh naively could scale
exponentially in the number of layers
epsilon is the target error and s is the
size of the network
which is some dimension independent
thing
okay the runtime looks similar um so we
need a nearly quadratic
dependence on the ambient dimension and
this sort of fixed parameter retractable
term
is going to be what we had here raised
to the s squared
power okay um
and so you know like i said like b here
uh
could you know feasibly just be
exponential in the
in the depth right if my operator norm
is bound by a constant each layer this
could be
uh you know two to the l um and so one
one thing we would like to avoid is some
kind of exponential dependence
a doubly exponential dependence on the
number of layers
and so we give sort of a compromise that
says
if i additionally assume that my relu
network is lipschitz
which is definitely the case for any of
the lower bound instances
against csq that i described earlier
then you could hope to do better as
follows
so note that capital b is always a naive
upper bound on the lips of the network
but in fact i can now replace any
appearance of b
in my uh upper bound with uh a lambda
at a very mild cost okay so i can
replace the b
with lambda and i incur some extra log
term
that depends on this the scaling factor
b
okay okay so now you you might be
complaining
that there's some strange dependence on
deliciousness which doesn't appear in
sort of existing techniques
in existing results for depth 2.
and i would like to point out that
actually even for depth 2
in the presence of lambda i's which are
of arbitrary sign
um you need at least some dependence on
lambda um
to get some kind of scale and variant
guarantee okay so
um i'm happy to describe this more uh in
the q a session but
i'll just i'll just state this as a
given for now um
okay great so but the main point i want
to make is that these results
go beyond the csq lower bounds that i
described
and you can think of it as the first
example of a neural network class that
can be learned efficiently
you know for if you treat the parameters
here as constants
but it's a class that can't be learned
efficiently
via noisy gradient descent in particular
the csq lower bounds
earlier would say that you need runtime
scaling exponentially in
in the uh say k um with the base
in that exponent being the ambient
dimension okay so we're avoiding this
kind of d
to the k runtime
okay pause for questions
all right great so now let me say a bit
about the results
sorry about the techniques okay and at a
high level the key technical challenge
is
um identifying the so-called relevant
subspace
for the underlying function okay so what
do i mean by that
so recall that uh when we think of the
effective dimension
k as being much less than d then
in essence the function that we're
trying to learn only depends on a small
dimensional space of the input
okay so in particular for any input x f
of x is exactly equal to
f evaluated on the projection of x to
the row span of w1
okay and so how could i try to get
access to the row span
so one approach based on stein's lemon
would be to look at
the matrix y times x transpose minus
identity
and one consequence of these csq lower
bounds
is that this matrix can actually be zero
for general real networks
okay in particular this is true for the
csq lower bound instances
in those works okay so what is a
sort of a simple way to get around this
issue well it would be to look at
slightly non-sq
uh queries uh non-csq queries
okay so let's consider the matrix which
is uh given by
phi of y times x transpose minus minus
identity
for a carefully chosen function phi
all right so it's still not hard to see
that for any choice of phi
for which capital n is defined the
kernel of this matrix
is still going to contain the sort of
irrelevant directions which i'll denote
by u perp
the orthogonal complement in the ambient
space
of u okay so how do you see this
let's look at the quadratic form
evaluated at v
and okay this splits up by independence
right so the point is that v
interproduct x is independent of
pi u x because v is orthogonal to u
okay so i can split this up into the
blue term and the green term
and let's say v is a unit vector so this
is nothing more than expectation over a
univariate gaussian
gamma of gamma squared minus one okay
and this integrates to zero
okay so this is this is super standard
and in a sense this is the only place
where we really need
properties of the gaussian as opposed to
some well-spread misconditions for you
know more general distributional
assumption okay um
so so this is this is very standard this
is just saying that if i want to look at
this matrix m
and i know for sure that if i find an
interesting eigenvector of this matrix
that's outside of the kernel
it will definitely be inside of the
relevant subspace
okay but of course the hard part is
ensuring that this matrix is non-zero to
begin with
i'd really like to say that the inner
product of my matrix
with the projector to the relevant
subspace is non-negligible
so let's write down the straight
interproduct this is
just the right-hand side and the key
difficulty in the analysis is handling
this minus k term right you can imagine
if my phi
function were non-negative and i didn't
have this minus k
here well this is going to be some
expectation over a positive function
and i'm going to get some positive inner
product and
i'll be in good shape to recover a
single direction
okay so how do we handle this minus k
term
well let's imagine i could produce some
function phi which satisfied following
three properties
first of all let's let's just ensure
that this phi is non-negative for all
inputs
let's constrain it to not be identically
zero when evaluated over different
choices of f
x this is just to ensure that the thing
we're integrating isn't actually
identically zero
and of course we'll need some
quantitative version of this later
okay and so the third and most important
property that we're going to work with
is the following constraint namely i
want
that phi of f x is non-zero
only if the norm of the projection of x
to the relevant subspace
is large okay so the constant positive
is
if the norm of the projection is small i
want to make sure that five f of x is
zero
okay so so here's a picture of uh a nice
choice of phi
um for any choice of x for which
the norm of the projection is small uh
five f of x is going to be zero
and only past this point am i going to
start seeing some non-zero things
okay so this is this is uh what i want
out of my phi function
and why would i be done in this case
let's take this trace interproduct
and let's just split up according to the
indicator of the following event
okay my x is either going to have small
large projection to the relevant
subspace or small projection
so i'm just splitting up one into the
indicator of two complementary events
okay and the point is that by property
three
the second term is going to be zero for
any x for which the projection is small
i'm constraining
five f x to be 0 by the constant
positive okay so this
the second term vanishes just by design
i'm just left with the first term and
now
note that this quantity here
if i constrain the projection to be
large this quantity is just at least k
and because phi here is non-negative
there are no such no cancellations so we
can just lower bound this by
k times the indicator times five f of x
and finally by property 2
i ensure that this guy is going to be
not identically 0.
okay so if i could ensure that phi
satisfies properties 1 2 and 3
then i would ensure that you know if i
had infinite samples
and i took and i could you know estimate
capital m
perfectly and take its top eigenvector
it would lie squarely inside the
relevant subspace u
and i would make progress okay
cool so how do we design centrify
here's a very simple choice of phi that
would work
take phi to just be the following
threshold function
so on inputs z for which the absolute
value of z is small
phi is going to output zero and for z
for which the absolute value is large
it's going to output one
okay and i'll justify this choice of
threshold tau
in in the next few slides okay so before
the cartoon that we had for what phi
should look like was something like this
and under this choice of phi we're going
to get something that looks more like a
step function
okay so at some point once the norm is
sufficiently
large it's going to trans uh transition
from having a response which is too
small
to having a response which is at least
tau
okay and let me just say this is
reminiscent of a well-known technique of
sliced inverse regression
where you essentially want to condition
your data
only on the xy's for which y is
within a certain range in the hope that
the conditional distribution on x
is going to look non-gaussian in the
directions that you're interested in
namely in this relevant subspace u
and so the key challenge is to sort of
make this kind of technique
quantitative and this sort of approach
was was used in
a previous work joint with ragu mecca to
learn
a different concept class called
low-rank polynomials
okay so let's just see if i plug in this
particular choice of phi
what does the trace inner product
calculation from the previous slides
look like
okay so here's just what i had on the
previous slides
let me let me move the k outside
and i claim that this actually
simplifies significantly because of
property three
right the point is that if five f of x
were
one namely if f of x were sufficiently
large an absolute value
then by property three i know that this
indicator will hold
that this indicator will output one
okay so in other words i can just
rewrite this
expectation as the expectation of five f
of x
which is just the expectation of the
indicator that f of x is sufficiently
large
okay and then this is just a probability
right so the trace inner product that we
want to lower bound in a quantitative
sense
is really the probability that my
response y
is sufficiently large in absolute value
okay so that'll be the sort of
quantitative version of bullet point two
that we'll
we'll talk about so i haven't proven for
you yet that for this particular choice
of tau
properties two and three go through but
let me just give you a cartoon that will
sort of convince you that this is
completely reasonable right so here is a
heat map for i think a two layer neural
network
just in two dimensions think of the
relevant subspace as just r2
okay and um for simplicity you know it's
it's kind of discretized so let's think
of
each color as like a level set instead
of as like uh
um some kind of continuous range okay
okay so the the ball of interest is this
ball of x's whose projection is too
small
and i want to say i want to pick tau
so that if my response is bigger than
tau in absolute value
i'm guaranteed that i'm outside of this
ball okay that's so it's easy to design
such a towel
let me just take the maximum value of my
network
over any input that comes from this ball
okay and logically if i see a point
whose response is bigger than that
i know it has to come from outside of
the ball
okay and so this picture kind of
suggests that
the answer to this should be sorry i
can't see my cursor
the this picture suggests the answer
should be that i take tau to be
effectively like this deep blue color
or like the value corresponding to that
so if i condition on my data being
bigger than that whatever value this
color blue corresponds to
it's like i'm conditioning on um the
following uh
like portion of my covariate
distribution
okay so i'm just filtering out all
points for which y is sufficiently small
and absolute value and i'm left with the
stuff in purple and this trace inner
product that i care about
is simply the probability mass of this
purple region
okay so this is this is all just sort of
like a cartoon to give you a sense for
why
it's very reasonable that i can try to
design a threshold for which all this
works out
let me just let me just prove it because
the the proof is quite simple
okay so why for this choice of tau can i
satisfy
property three for instance namely that
f
x is big in absolute value only if the
projection is large
okay let's show the function positive so
let's say the projection is small
and i want to show that f of x is small
okay this is just a straightforward
consequence of lipsnes
so if i take my f of x recall that x
f of x only depends on the projection of
x to pi of u
so this is the first step and now by
liciousness
this quantity is at most the value of f
at zero
absolute valued plus lipschitz parameter
times the norm of pi ux
okay and now f of zero
remember this is a homogeneous neural
network there are no bias terms
so this is simply zero right
uh so this is uh and and i'm i'm
assuming that pi
pi u x has bounded norm and so i get the
final inequality
okay so so i'm done so property three
holds this is
not too bad okay a slightly
more involved calculation comes with
proving
step two so i'll just give you a high
level idea of this
okay so recall that the thing i wanted
to show quantitatively
wasn't just that 5x of x is not
identically zero
i really want to show that that the
probability that f of x is large
is large okay in other words i want to
show some kind of anti-concentration
for this function f
okay and so the proof idea is as follows
i'm going to exploit
piecewise linearity of my network
okay so if the network has
a non-negligible second moment in other
words if f
if expectation of y squared is
non-negligible
then on average over the pieces of f the
linear pieces of f that you can see in
these
cells demarcated by white
a linear piece is going to have some
variance and therefore some level of
anti-concentration
okay for each of these linear pieces
it's not
too bad to try to lower bound this
anti-concentration property
that probability in fact you can lower
bounded by a convex function in the
variance
conditional variance in that linear
piece
okay and why is it important this lower
balance convex
this is so you can apply jensen's and
law of total variance
okay so if on average the variance of a
linear piece is
is large uh jensen's is going to tell me
that the
anti-concentration probability overall
is going to be large
okay so that's that's a very high level
description of the proof
let me just summarize with the the punch
line
so this tells me that if my network has
some reasonable amount of variance
and i pick my threshold appropriately
then if i condition my data on points
whose absolute value is
sufficiently large and i look at the
conditional covariance
then i'm going to discern from that
covariance
an interesting direction namely a vector
inside of capital u
okay and because the top eigenvalue has
some non-negative value this means that
if i form
an empirical estimate of my matrix using
enough samples
and compute the top eigenvector it's
going to be close to
the subspace i care about
okay and so you could be even more
ambitious and ask well
if i just took the full spectrum of m
all of the non-zero
eigenvectors of m could i hope to
recover just the full subspace
um and it seems like empirically this
isn't necessarily true for
certain choices of f um and
uh in particular if you if you test this
on uh the csq instance i think um
one of adam's students found this uh
you might be able to recover one
direction but you're definitely not
gonna recover the full relevant subspace
u
okay so the million dollar question is
how do you recurse we found one
direction how do you find the remaining
directions inside of this relevant
subspace
okay and i claim that with a simple fix
to this whole thresholding scheme a lot
of the analysis from the previous slides
you can actually pattern match to get
the remaining
directions in the subspace okay so now
let me talk about
about that so our goal is to find the
remaining directions inside of u
we found some vector v and we'd like to
find another vector v
prime which is orthogonal to v and
inside of u
okay i think i see a question in the q a
but i can't access
the span of nabla fx as x varies
or more algorithmically okay so the
question is um another way to get the
relevant subspace is by taking the span
of nabla f of x as x varies
or more algorithmically
sort of like the expected projector to
the gradient at a point
do you know how this compares to your
estimator yeah it's a good question i
um
my instinct is that this uh
it's it's conceivable this this kind of
thing you could try out on depth two
but uh uh
yeah it's not it's not clear to me um
how the analysis will go for larger
depth but yeah it's definitely
something uh like an alternative
approach i don't i don't have anything
um
uh sort of substance to say about this
uh but
that's a good question i'll have to
think about offline
okay good so um so let's go back to
finding the rest of the relevant
directions um
okay so this is the matrix that we
considered in the previous slides
um so one sort of silly way to try to
avoid
finding the same vector again this this
vector v
would be to add projectors to the
orthogonal complement on left and right
okay this is this is kind of silly like
if this worked if i could show that the
top eigenvector of this matrix
was some new relevant direction v prime
i could have just
made that same argument about the
original matrix okay so
what kind of modification do i need i'm
going to modify
this part of the of the definition of
the matrix so instead of thresholding on
the response
i'm going to threshold on essentially
the residual
okay so let's consider the residual
computed as the absolute difference
between the true response
and the response that would have been
calculated if i took my input
projected in the direction of v and put
it through f
so of course i don't actually have
access to this object
and i'll talk about this in later slides
but for now let's pretend we have access
to this
this object okay so it's still easy to
see that the kernel of this matrix is
going to contain the relevant subspace's
orthogonal complement as before
and it's also by design going to contain
the span of v
okay and that's just because we added
these orthogonal projectors
and as before the hard part is just to
lower bound this trace inner product
okay so let's just write that out okay
so previously how did we handle this
kind of term
let me just reproduce the slides from
before
summarized and let me now show you how
to
sort of edit this arc this whole
argument to make the
analysis still go through for finding
subsequent directions
okay so let me just recall that
you can rewrite this trace inner product
as a probability
okay so the first modification is to the
definition of m
okay so now the trace inner product we
care about is this thing i showed on the
previous slide
so how do these two properties that i
want uh change so the first property
instead of probability that absolute
value of y is large being large
i want the probability that the residual
being large is large
the second property i want before it was
that
the response is large only if the
projection was large
and now i want that the residual is
large only if the projection is large
and because i've projected away the the
span of v i only care about x which are
orthogonal to v
okay um and finally okay so the trace
inner product instead of being lower
bounded by this probability
that the response is large it's going to
be lower bounded by the probability that
the residual is large okay so
so far i've just pattern matched and
things are fine
now let me see how to handle properties
one and two
okay so property two i wanna show that
the residual is large
only if the projection is large
so let's take any x which is orthogonal
to v
and i would like to show that if the
projection is small then the residual is
small
and this is just going to be by lifting
this again so f of x minus f of pi v of
x
i can first rewrite f of x as f of pi u
x
and by liciousness i can upper bound
this by lambda times the norm of
the difference which is going to be pi
of uh
the projection of x to the orthogonal
complement
of v inside of u and i've assumed that
this
projection is small to begin with so
again i can lower i can upper bound this
by lambda times
root two k minus two okay so property
two is going to hold
if i pick my threshold to be to be this
this value
lambda times root 2 k minus 2. okay so
this is very similar to what happened in
finding the first direction
and similarly for this anti-constant
anti-concentration result um we can make
the following argument that's also
reminiscent of the previous slides
so it's just a simple women argument
either the unexplained variance is large
in other words i can't explain all the
variance
using just this one direction v
in this case the sort of residual
function
f of x minus f of pi v of x
it's still piecewise linear so we can
just apply the argument from earlier
okay uh sorry about that okay and then
the other case is if the unexplained
variance is small
well in that case we've already won if i
had access to this object f of pi v of x
and this l2 distance between
y and f pi v x were small
then i could just output f pi v x and
i'd be done
i would have pac learned the underlying
network
okay so that's that's the high level
overview for how this argument works
okay and to summarize what this gives us
is that if we found
some collection of directions so far um
inside of the relevant subspace and i
call their span
v then the claim is i can find something
that is orthogonal to v
and still inside of u as long as there's
still some leftover variance
okay so this is saying if i form this
matrix m prime which filters y's
based on the magnitude of the residual
and i look at the resulting covariance
of the x's
this is going to have kernel which is
inside
this irrelevant subspace u perp direct
sum v
in particular the top eigenvalue is
going to be bounded away from zero so so
if i take
the top eigenvector of m prime i'm going
to find a new direction which is
orthogonal to capital v
and still lies squarely inside of you
okay so that's that's the sort of uh
infinite sample
uh idealized calculation if i also had
access to this f f of pi v x
at every step i just iteratively run
this until i recover the full relevant
subspace
or i've terminated with a function
that's close enough
in l2 to the true network
okay um so there's one complication
uh to this which is of course that i
don't know this particular function
but i i do know this this vector space v
right these are the
directions i found so far
and particular v is going to be some
some small dimensional subspace
so particular f of pi v x is just going
to be
some small rayleigh network over a known
subspace
and so the idea is just to net over
possible networks
that are functions of v
okay so i'm just going to exhaustively
enumerate over this net
another issue is that you can only
ensure that the directions that you
found so far
are close to a subspace v first because
you only have finally many samples and
second of all because you have some
error from
netting over networks okay
and so the key technical complication is
to understand like how stable is this
entire argument
um with respect to these kinds of
imperfections
um and so the key technical step is uh
to understand the stability of affine
threshold functions
of rayleigh networks so what do i mean
by this
so let me now go to the key stability
result so really all i'm
all i mean by stability of affine
thresholds of networks
is if i take some uh rayleigh network
and i slightly modify its parameters to
get something that looks
slightly different and now i want to
compute some
threshold function maybe i want to
compute the threshold
that dictates you know whether something
is bigger than this value corresponding
to this dark blue color
or less than that value well if i
sort of walk between these two networks
this area um computed by this this
threshold is going to defer slightly
so now if i superimpose these two
networks really all i want to upper
bound
is the gaussian volume of this area of
disagreement
where in one network
i'm in the dark blue region and in the
other i am not
okay all right and so in math what this
means is if i have two rayleigh networks
with let's say with the same
architecture and whose weight matrices
are close in operator norm
then the probability that the absolute
value of f of x
being large for one network and small
for the other
is small
okay um good uh so let me remind you
uh this capital b here is the product of
the operator norms of the weight
matrices
and how should i interpret alpha in the
course of our algorithm i'm going to try
invoking this on alpha which
essentially corresponds scales with the
granularity of the
net over networks that i'm working with
and i want to pick
the the granularity of that net to scale
with the subspace distance
between the span of the directions i
found so far
and the relevant subspace
okay and let me emphasize that really we
care about
the dependence on alpha here being
linear
because essentially because we need to
you know
operary we need to iterate this whole
argument k times i find a direction
i iterate to find a new direction and
what i want to avoid is
some kind of buildup in the exponent so
if i only had a bound that scaled with
say alpha to the 0.99
this would yield sample complexity
naively that would have to scale w
exponentially in k
okay so um let me give like a 10
000 foot overview of how to prove this
llama
and um so so one key takeaway that i
hope
you have from from from listening to
this talk is the following very nice
fact
um proven like
uh by of chinekov in the early 2000s
so basically the whole argument's going
to boil down to some kind of
hybrid argument on you can think of some
kind of depth-reduced network
so i take any continuous piecewise
linear function
and according to this result of chinekov
you can
rewrite it as a depth to maximum formula
so think of this as like a cnf but
instead of and or gates
you have max and min gates and the
leaves are linear functions in the input
okay so really we'll need to open up the
black box for this result
um for technical reasons that i won't
get into
but at a high level this is like the
workhorse behind our stability analysis
so how do we use this to prove our lemma
so here's the limo again and the proof
idea is
essentially just hybrid argument let's
look at the maximum representations for
these two rayleigh networks
and let's call them phi and phi prime
now let me open up the black box of the
china cod result
and essentially argue that these should
actually have the same clause structure
okay and once i have that in place it's
very clear what the
sort of sequence of intermediate maximum
formulas that i should interpolate along
should be consider the following
sequence of hybrids between these two
formulas
at every step i'm going to interchange
one of the leaves
at the top with one of the leaves at the
bottom
okay so i'm going to replace u1 into
product x with w1 interproduct x to form
the first hybrid
etc okay so i can uh interpolate
uh just by swapping out leaves and
eventually i'm going to end up with
another copy of five prime
okay so i won't get into the details of
this but uh the
the whole point is that if you compare
consecutive pairs of hybrids
then actually showing this disagreement
probability bound
in the lemma boils down to showing
stability
not of thresholds of relu networks but
simply thresholds of
linear functions okay
and that's just an elementary estimate
okay so that's that's essentially the
whole proof for this ability argument
let me just
conclude by sort of summarizing what the
algorithm looks like
okay so here's here's the whole
algorithm you start off with a list of
vectors that's empty
and this is going to be sort of the list
of vectors that i accumulate
which i guarantee to be close in the
relevant subspace over
over time okay and
you know i'm going to repeatedly do the
following let's let v
be the span of the vectors we found so
far
i'm going to net overall networks over
the span
if i encounter some network in this net
which achieves low square loss
i'm done and i can i can perically
estimate the square loss
so if this is the case i'll just output
the network
otherwise if that's not the case
i could still try forming this
thresholded
pca kind of matrix which again you know
i threshold based on the residual
where instead of the true f i'm going to
look at this f hat
okay and the point is that you know if v
were exactly a subspace of u
and i found some interesting eigenvalue
of this matrix
it's guaranteed to be within the
relevant subspace i won't have found
some kind of dud
okay and the way i check
whether the vector i found is is not
some spurious thing is just to check
whether
the eigenvalue of that vector is
sufficiently large
okay so in the case where the spectral
norm of my matrix is sufficiently large
um i've sort of succeeded in this
epoch so i'm going to take that
eigenvector that i found i'm going to
add it to my list
and by the proceeding analysis this
ensures that i found something that's in
the relevant subspace or close to it
and then i'll just repeat i'll keep
running this and at every step i'm going
to
encounter more vectors to add into my
list
and finally at some point i'm going to
hit the first bullet point
in step b and i'm going to find that my
vector or
my network that i've learned actually
achieves low square loss and at this
point i'm just going to output
the resulting network okay so that's the
full algorithm
so now let me just conclude uh the brief
summary and
i'll just i'll leave on the slides a set
of open questions
okay so the the summary is that it was
known that csq algorithms like noisy
grain descent
and these kinds of spectral and tensor
initialization procedures based on
science lemma fail to learn general
two-layer rayleigh networks over
gaussian inputs
and we got around this barrier by
instead working with slightly non-csq
statistics
of the form phi of y minus f of x
times g of x okay um
in the process we gave uh an algorithm
which is fixed parameter tractable
although with an exponential dependence
on the error epsilon
um for learning general relu networks of
arbitrary depth over
over gaussian inputs
good okay so so in terms of open
questions there are plenty
um the the most obvious one is of course
to improve the dependence on
all the parameters that aren't the
ambient dimension
some other questions you could ask that
might be sort of related in spirit
are could you get some kind of local
convergence guarantee
namely use the whole procedure in this
algorithm as some kind of spectral
initialization
and then run some some kind of iterative
method to refine your estimate
um in light of the csq lower bounds this
uh this
turns out to be a bit complicated so
it's not clear this is possible
um at least with you know green descent
on
square loss okay another question of
course is
can you go beyond the you know standard
gaussian
gaussian assumption um and like i said
like we
really crucially used gaussianity to
argue that all the matrices we've been
working with
their kernel contains those irrelevant
directions
um but a lot of these anti-concentration
arguments you can you can imagine
with some extra work still applying to
log lot concave distributions for
instance
so another um sort of open secret in
this literature is that uh
these results are primarily tailored to
the
setting where you don't have bias terms
um
and you know we really heavily exploited
that in the arguments in this talk
namely the homogeneity of the function
computed by the network
and once you introduce the bias terms
like you know it's no longer
no longer clear how to make any progress
um ironically like our our arguments
are you know very successful for regular
activations
and less successful for sigmoid
activations um
and crucially it seems like um
we're definitely using the piecewise
linearity of the relay activation but
we're also
you know very crucially using its
unboundedness
so another direction to push on would be
to try to
go beyond exploiting that so heavily
okay and the last question is maybe you
know um
uh right now you're seeing we're seeing
like exorbitant uh sample complexity
dependence on
the size of the network and the
effective dimension um
but this is essentially because we're
picking a rather pessimistic choice of
tau
in order to ensure that we provably find
a new direction
but you could hope to evaluate this kind
of slice inverse regression um
empirically on these kinds of networks
and and you know see what happens
and this might inform you know smarter
analyses for for this kind of
thresholding argument um
yeah so i'm sure there are plenty of
other open questions that i'm happy to
just discuss
in the q a or offline but for now thanks
for listening
great great great job any questions for
satan
i mean i feel kind of weird asking a
question about my own work so
i'm not going to um
but uh
yeah so let's stop here um thanks again
satan for a terrific talk
and we'll meet again uh tomorrow
or a day primarily on graphical models
so we'll see you then thank you thanks